[音楽]
今日は下記ひな子です
明治大学で法律を勉強しています
それだけっと言ってしまうとそれだけです
普通はこういったて dx の舞台に立つ人って
国際て的な経験があったり騎乗経験があったり
発信力のある人だと思います
私はそういった特別はありません
以下って普通の大学生です
ですが19歳という
この年だからこそ大学生という立場だからこそ伝えられることがあると思いました
また今普通といったんですが実はルールに対して敏感に感じていた時期もありました
今日ズバリ私が伝えたいことそれは集団ルールです
ルールというものが集団を縛るものというイメージ
皆さんあると思います
ですがルーっていうのマイルームやっぱり個人ルードといったものもあります
なので私は今回集団というものを強調したいんです
私の長所は自信があるところそして
考えを表現しようとするところです一方で
打たせてどうしていつもこうなんだと思ってしまうことがあります
みんなが当たり前に受け入れていることあ
例えばレール
a
なぜなのかと素直に受け入れられず反発しました
私と同じような経験はありますか
少数かもしれないですがいるかなと思います
また納得できない状況そのものにぶつかりそうになった経験はあるのではないでしょう
か
あとこれは学生に限った話ではないと思うんです
あれやれこれやれルールはルールだから
特に高速これは大変画一的なものでした
ですが私はたった一人で抵抗したんです
根底には世の中にはなぜルールが存在するんだろうかという疑問がありました
高校生の時担任の先生に
実は校則についての意見書を提出したことがあります
髪を結ばなければならないという高速に対する意見書です
そのルードに合理的な理由はあるのだろうか
髪を結ぶと本当に集中力は上がるのだろうか
高速を守るという主体性は賭けはしないだろうか
私は本当にそのようなルールが嫌で嫌で一人で文献調べてみるという偉人発言も尻もし
たし
パターンナリスのという言葉についても調べたけないです
そしてこの件に対して私の担任の先生は頭ごなしに否定はしませんでした
考えることはとても良いことだとも言ってくれたんです
先生はなぜルール守る必要があるのか
であったりルールを変えるためにはどうすればいいのかといったアドバイスをくれまし
た
心の中で女形として言った言葉ことを言葉で
明確に証言してくれたのです
確かにと思ったんです
鉄鋼や犯行を自分がしているのには少なからずおかしいという思いがあったからで
えっおかしいと思ったからにはその理由を突き詰めたいと考え末考えました
こういう事を皆さんもあるのではないでしょうか
本当に
a
納得してないことを分かっているようで分かってはいないこと
ここで犯行を諦めて従うことはできます
普通は従います
下丸屋嫌で仕方なかった私は平和に収めるいい方法を見つけました
わかりましたと笑顔で言えばいいんです
ちょっと行って見てもらってもいいでしょうか
私が皆さんに根拠なくルールだからと言います
私が普段の皆さんの上司や先輩がと想像してください
皆さんが分かりましたと笑顔で言ってください
全部で3回やります
メレーいいですね
あーるーの腫を発症さ
ぬなんでしょうねるーるー
まったく受けましたかこれはえって思いましたよ
その時は従前にやり過ごしたとしても本当に納得できていないと意味がないんです
さらにおかしいと自分が感じた時に感情が張り出してしまうと思うんです
ブラック高速という言葉知っていますか
理不尽が高速に疑問を抱く学生たちが非常に増えているという現状があります
ここで話をまとめると私ってどうしていつもこうなんだわかっているようでわかってい
ないルール
本当に納得はしていないという経験が私にはありました
そしてそれはどうも私だけではないようです
そして冒頭にお伝えした集団ルードゥ
これが私が発見した新しいマインドです
担任の先生からルールについてのアドバイスがあって
そこから台のルール嫌いだった
私がルールについて知りたいと思い法学部へ進学しました
ん
方を通して考え方そのものを学んでいるうちに徐々にルールについての理解が出てき
ました
そもそもルールとは何でしょうか
私は先ほど例に高速を出しましたがそれだけではないですよね
ルールはほぼすべてのコミュニティにあるはずです
また心人間同士の暗黙のルールもあると思います
ルールについて調べていくうちに2つの食麺があると分かりました
束縛と自由です
自由を守るための束縛なのです
想像してみてくださいもし人を殺したらいけないというルールがなかったらどうなり
ますか
皆さんがお忙しくて自由に外に出られなくなりますよ
もし義務教育が無かったらどうでしょうか
義務教育があるからこそ私たちは職業の選択が出来てます
これはルールがもしなかったらを想像してみるといいでしょう
ないことで究極スタンリーキューブリック監督の映画である
パッケージ学園のオレンジのような秩序のない暴力的な世界が持っているかもしれませ
ん
だっぱら守ることによっていいことがあるという明るい未来をイメージしてみましょう
頭を切り替えることでより広い視野を得られるのではないでしょうか
私はルールは自分のためにあるのではなく集団のためにあると思うようになりました
これが周南レイドという考え方であり
私が新たに得たマインドです
私だけが守るものそれはあくまでも自分ルールであって世の中のレールは世の中の為に
作られているということです
これは自分のことだけ考えていた私に気づかなかったの自由という
作目んですねしかもあまり一員としての実感はないかもしれませんが集団ルールを上る
とそこには自分を含まれているわけです
集団ルールとは個人自由を守るために
あるルールなんです
もし今後もフリーな場面や理不尽なことをされた時であったとしても今までだったら
浸すが束縛を感じていたと思います
ですが今後はもしかしたら守ることによって自由の側面があると考えていきたいです
そこに a ことがあるのかもしれない
そう考えていきたいです
そうすることでどうですかね切羽詰まらず冷静に考えられるのではないでしたっ
皆さんに私が最も伝えたいことそれは集団0でです
ルールには束縛だけでなく自由という側面があります
ルールはすでにその主旨がありますそのルールをやみくもに守る反発するのではなく
一度ルールの背景を考えてみてはいかがでしょうか
私のように反発心が強い人でも今までだったら
従いたくないと思うんですけど
えっとそうするとその通りに頑固になってしまって事態は悪化する
明石がちなんですね
それを避けるために身の回りのルールについて
皆さんも束縛と知恵の両面を考えてみてください
集団ルールとは個人は日目にあるルールです
個人の自由を守るために集団ルールがあります
もし理不尽な場面にあった時
集団ルールという言葉をぜひ思い出して打ってくださいありがとうございました
[拍手]